[Applause]
[Applause]
on jokic
down goes kane and across the face and
here we go
cameron payne is still down and we've
got the two superstars
going john a john here in jokic
and devin booker
[Applause]
here's the foul here in the swipe and we
got all ball
i'm sure they'll look at this but there
is some
kind of a wind-up and hits them on the
shoulder the wind-up is though yeah
that's the wind-up right there
oh yeah he definitely got him in the
face absolutely across the nose see
something like this you can break your
nose
yeah i see this being a flagrant one
because of the wind-up
kevin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yoga and that's a lot to carry
especially when murray went down
right and he played every game this year
72 on his candy tunes
on his campaign for winning mvp but this
is a frustration foul he felt that he
was fouled they didn't call it
and there's the wind-up and the swing
[Applause]
i'm wondering why people are upset here
this is absolutely a flagrant one
[Applause]
[Music]
it can get grizzly
if it's a flagrant on jokic it would be
his first
in the last three seasons
[Music]
well if you're michael malone what did
he call him soft
he said they quit needs to be quest this
is what he's been looking for right
the problem is they're down three
nothing and right now chris paul
devin booker are cooking them to the
tune of 49
points
love book that's what book is supposed
to do now
jay crowler's supposed to come in and
grab him because you don't want anything
happen to devin booker
bridges is trying to get him away
well what do you think i think it's the
wind-up i think this is the flagrant one
the wind-up is the most i mean the
optics tell you that that
probably is and it crosses where they
begin yes
[Music]
these two teams have been at each other
a lot this season
in two of the games in the regular
season they both went to overtime
third one was a one possession game
and the road team won all three
in this series we have seen the suns
win and win handily
by 17 25 and 14 points again here's the
foul by jokic
in my opinion the wind up across the
face of cameron payne
as he's going for the basketball
[Applause]
he's very fortunate he didn't get his
nose broken on that and then
and then those were these two exactly
devin booker the joker the mvp
jokage going nose to nose here
maybe this wakes up the nuggets because
right now the suns
have been having their way not only
throughout this series
but tonight and maybe this takes a
little bit of the steam
over a replay review there is and cb3
wind-up impact and follow-through it is
a flagrant penalty two on jokic
he's ejected from the game there is also
a technical foul on booker
for the actions during the dead ball
unfortunately
our mic is not working over there
[Applause]
we're going to take you now to secaucus
jason phillips will join us jason what
did you see what was the conversation
like
[Applause]
hey kevin reggie go ahead jason what the
official saw during review here
uh by jokic was wind-up impact
and follow-through all to the extent
of unnecessary and excessive contact
therefore it met the criteria for a
flagrant foul penalty two
in this situation after the officials
looked at that
they felt like that it checked those
boxes and therefore
deemed it to play without penalty two
and then devin booker
was assessed to flagrant or excuse me a
technical foul
for the interaction with yokit after the
flagrant foul
two well now
jokic is gone wow uh
i'm a little surprised i certainly had a
flagrant one
but i understand where they're coming
from about the wind up and the follow
through
across the face of cameron payne
[Applause]
and your mvp is done
for the night and possibly for his
season
before he left jokic did go over and
speak to payne
and then walked off as we saw
i have to say i've seen a lot worse that
turned
into just a flavor of one
i'm a little surprised that he would get
a free room cheat on that
great sportsmanship it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as we talked about and the last word he
said too
violently to the face of cameron payne
as the official pat prayer came over
and explained their decision behind that
the wind-up and the violent act to the
face
of cameron payne
payne two's up at three offensive foul
on payne
with the lane kick
he was over there on the close by
compazo and payne will pick it up
things being thrown on the floor here
from the fans